2026년 4월 27일 월요일 미국 증시 유약입니다.
금일 미국 증시는 혼조세였습니다.
S&P 500 지수와 나스닥 지수는 작년에 등락을 거듭한 끝에 나란히 사상 최고치를 경신했습니다.
하지만 이란 평화협상이 교착상태에 빠지고 호르무즈의 협을 둘러싼 긴장이 다시 고조되면서 전반적인 상승폭은 제한적이었습니다.
주말 사이 트럼프 대통령은 이란 휴전 협상을 위해 스티브 위커프 미국 특사와 제로드 쿠슈너를 파키스탄에 파견하려던 계획을 정격 취소하며 협상은 전화로도 충분히 가능하다고 밝혔습니다.
한편 이란은 호르무즈의 협을 재개방하고 전쟁을 끝내자는 내용의 새로운 타협안을 미국 측에 제안한 것으로 전해졌습니다.
이에 대해 백악관은 이란의 최근 제안을 논의 중이라고 밝히면서도 이란의 핵무기 보유 차단이라는 레드라인만큼은 결국 약속했습니다.
그간 반도체 주는 실적 호주에 대한 기대감과 인공지능 투자 심리 회복에 힘입어 사상 최장인 18거래의 연속 상승세를 이어 왔지만 이날로 그 흐름이 끊겼습니다.
특히 반도체 지수는 마벨 테크놀로지발 악재로 하락 압력을 받았습니다.
마벨의 자회사인 셀레스티럴 AI가 호웻 테크놀로지에 대한 구매 주문을 취소하면서 호웻의 주가가 47%나 폭락했습니다.
퀄컴의 경우 상승 마감하긴 했으나 장 초반에 비해서는 오른 폭을 상당 부분 반납했습니다.
앞서 퀄컴이 오픈 AI와 스마트폰 프로세서 개발을 위해 협력하고 있다는 관측이 나오면서 주가가 강세를 보인 바 있습니다.
이제 투자자들의 시선은 주요 빅테크 기업들의 실적 발표로 쏠리고 있습니다.
현재 시간 수요일에는 구글, 마이크로소프트, 아마존, 메타가 일제히 성적표를 내놓으며 바로 다음 날에는 애플의 실적이 이어집니다.
더불어 투자자들은 이란 전쟁이 경제에 미친 파장과 관련해 주요 중앙은행들이 어떤 평가를 내놓을지도 예의주시하고 있습니다.
이번 주에는 미국과 유럽을 비롯해 일본, 영국, 캐나다 등 주요국 중앙은행들의 기준금리 결정이 줄줄이 예정되어 있습니다.
나빌레노소시스의 루이스나스는요.
나빌레는 최근 증시 상승세가 인공지능품에 영향을 받았던 만큼 이 상승 동료를 이어가려면 이른바 매그니피센트 세븐의 향후 전망과 투자 지출 계획이 중요하다.
팔콘 웰스의 가브레 샤이는 지적적 변수는 여전히 시장에 큰 영향을 미치고 있다.
라고 전하였습니다.
2026년 4월 28일 화요일 주요 일정 살펴보겠습니다.
경제지표는 12시 일본.
문의결정 22시 미국 2월 주택가격지수 23시 미국 4월 리치몬드 여는 제조업지수 23시 미국 4월 컨퍼런스보드 소비자 신뢰지수 02시 미국 7년물 국채 경매가 예정되어 있습니다.
감사합니다.